dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on alpha here this
episode is about a classic the
dunning-kruger effect I wonder how we
could go on for almost sixty two minute
papers episodes without the
dunning-kruger effect here's the
experiment participants were tested in
different subjects their test scores
were computed and at the same time
without the scores they were asked to
assess their perceived performance the
test subjects were humour grammar and
logic things of course everyone excels
it for today and here is the historic
plot with the results such a simple plot
yet it tells us so much about people
from left to right people were ordered
by their test score as you see with the
dotted line and the other line with the
squares shows their perceived score what
they thought their scores would be
people from the bottom 10% the absolute
worst performers are convinced that they
were well above the average competent
people on the other hand seemed to
underestimate their skills because the
test was easy for them they assumed that
it was easy for everyone else the
extreme to the left is often referred to
as the dunning-kruger effect and the
extreme to the right maybe if you
imagine the lines extending way way
further to the right is a common example
of impostor syndrome by the way everyone
thinks they are above average which is a
neat mathematical anomaly we would
expect that people who perform poorly
should note that they perform poorly and
people who are doing great should know
that they are doing great and one of the
conclusions is that this is not the case
not the case at all
the fact that incompetent people are
completely ignorant about their own
inadequacy at first sounds like such a
surprising conclusion but if we think
about it we find there is nothing
surprising about this the more skilled
we are the more adept we are at
estimating our skill level by gaining
more competence incompetent people also
obtain the skill to recognize their own
shortcomings a fish in the world of
Poker means an inadequate player who is
to be extorted by the more experienced
someone asked how to
who the fishes at the poker table the
answer is a classic if you don't know
who the fish is at the table it is you
the knowledge of the dunning-kruger
effect is such a tempting tool to
condemn other people for their
inadequacy but please try to resist the
temptation remember it doesn't help
that's the point of the paper it is a
much more effective tool for our own
development if we attempt to use it on
ourselves
does it hurt a bit more oh yes it does
the results of this paper solidify the
argument that we need to be very
vigilant about our own shortcomings this
knowledge involves you with the shield
against ignorance use it wisely thanks
for watching and for your generous
support and I'll see you next time